coût selon le guide alimentaire canadien
on devrait manger un minimum de cinq
portions de fruits et légumes par jour
au canada ya à peu près 20% de la
population donc une personne sur cinq
qui vont manger le minimum de cinq
portions de fruits par jour et de
légumes
1 2 3 4 5 et est qu il ya quatre-vingts
pour cent des canadiens qui mangent même
poste dans une journée
[Musique]
mais selon un condensé de 95 études
internationales parus ces dernières
années il faudrait en manger au moins 10
on s'est rendu compte que quelqu'un qui
mangerait l'équivalent de 10 portions de
fruits et légumes donc en grammes pour à
l'européenne celle 800 grammes aussi
tout le monde mangeait ça on pourrait
prévenir par année 7.8 millions de décès
je pense que pas grand chose qui peut à
côté ça avec hélène on s'est amusé à
calculer ce qui représente 10 portions
où 800 grammes par jour
et combien ça coûte à prix courants 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 portions commence à
coude sont en plein hiver au québec
ce ça coûte 3 $ et 96
puis un gros cafés starbucks ça coûte 4
pièces aussi cher et le cadre de la cour
10 portions on sera en meilleure santé
si tout le monde mangeait ces dix
portions ou huit portions peut-être pour
les enfants il y aurait moins
d'hypertension il y aurait moins de
diabète il y aurait moins d'obésité et
dans une journée 10 portions si ça j'ai
vraiment étonné que ce soit à 10
portions je pensais que ça allait être
difficile à atteindre
les gens pensent que 10 portions
l'autiste une montagne de fruits légumes
une portion c'est un fruit moyens une
demi tasse de légumes ou une tasse de
laitue les fruits séchés 1/4 de tasse
mais 80 g de choula ces deux styles deux
petits bouquets l'autre 80 g de chocolat
alors là on est déjà en a deux portions
et c'est dans notre assiette
[Musique]
mes plus beaux souvenirs alimentaire
quand j'étais jeune
pourtant on était bobo un végétarien la
maison mais c'est tout le temps autour
des légumes
le chef stelio perombelon a toujours
fait belle place aux légumes de l'entrée
au dessert
voici une forêt de brocolis à la césar
on est loin du bol de brocoli bouillie
sont tellement tentant c'est trop à
propre attire avec les enfants un plat
comme ça je sors ça peut faire des
miracles
parce que s'est dressé comme ça puis la
gestuelle je pense que ça s'appelait
c'est tellement beau certaines que même
les gens qui aiment pas le brocoli va
tenter au moins d'avec brutalité
effectivement fourneaux plupart à sucre
c'est un âne assure-t-on comptoirs de
cuisine là un bel âne à pitre un pilote
leurs gammes
puis là il faut que quelqu'un prenne la
planche le couteau varrault les doigts
colis il va falloir qu'ils coupent et
messer dessus tu fais pitié sont sur la
table
au spi en famille pitt tom hanson c'est
sûr que ça va se manger un peu d'efforts
et nous voici avec ce beau tartare rouge
sans viande
il s'agit de betteraves
il y aussi le jeu derrière cela il ya
cet intérêt de s'amuser avec le client
puis lui rappeler des plots qui connaît
déjà l'équivalent combien de betteraves
là dedans j'irai deux bonnes betteraves
métrage qu'on fait c'est qu'on les fait
cuire au four
classiquement depuis quelques années on
voit qu'il est jeune et enveloppé dans
du papier aluminium nous on fait même
pas sûr on les met sur une plaque au
four directement salé ratatine un petit
peu et ça leur donne presque une texture
de de chair crue un peu ça peut se dire
un peu de gomme un peu comme un jugement
et c'est là que ça devient intéressant
moi je pense quand ça déshydrate plus
que ça ça devient un peu collant comme
une viande crue cuit au congeler les
fruits et légumes
on les trouve à l'année mais qu'en est
il des jus de fruits ou de légumes qui
se vendent parfois de contenir jusqu'à
deux portions par verre mais surtout en
pressant si je presse mon orange pour
obtenir le jus d'orange
mais toute la pulpe tout l'enveloppent
toutes les fibres vont rester là et moi
je vais boire seulement les glucides
seulement donc la portion avec l'eau
sucrée avec et vitamines dans le jus de
légumes ou de tomates
le problème c'est c'est le seul qui peut
être vraiment en quantité astronomique
privilégiez les aliments entiers c'est
ce que fait stellio avec ce risotto de
pommes de terre les pommes de terre
soient yuko ou les pommes de terre de
type al at elle son cru elles sont plus
mais j'essaie de garder la pelure est ce
qu'on fait ici c'est que j'ai coupé
comme un grain de riz en guinée un peu
plus long
[Musique]
donc on voit que le liquide devient un
peu plus blanc que l'amidon se libère
dans l'aude c'est ce qui va faire la
liaison un peu comme pour le riz couvert
de champignons et de différentes pouces
pour un plateau végétal
les chefs sont en train de prendre le
virage légumes
de plus en plus et de plus en plus on va
traiter le légume au restaurant avec le
même soin avec le même souci qu'on vote
faire à ce qui coûte cher au restaurant
le poisson la viande les gens vont
prendre conscience que c'est une belle
façon de travailler avec nos produits
locaux
nos corps nos racines en hiver
ici le la moitié de notre assiette ce
sont des fruits ou des légumes l'autre
car ce serait mettons-nous féculents
notre orge notre hymne pommes de terre
nous partez thérapie l'autre cas ce
serait nous notre viande de volaille
notre poisson magistrat déjà sur la
table on a un tableau le pierrier mraz
l'homme et la nature mort mais moi je
dirais nature vivent
[Musique]